Allow me to introduce my Spirit Ally.
Blamuro, the vampire hunter.
And I
am Boris Tepes Dracula.
A vampire.
A vampire hunter
and Dracula?
Cut the crap! Dracula is
a fictional character from a novel!
Besides, if anyone's Dracula,
it's got to be that geezer over there!
Yes, you're right!
It's his hair and his beard!
There are only five of them,
so why do they have two of the same type?
Man, that's lame!
You won't get away with that!
Being likened to such
a shabby-looking man as he
is the gravest insult!
What?
Now my unique identity is protected.
Forgive me, Damayaji.
It's all their fault
for uttering such malicious slander.
My friend, please do me the kindness
of living on in me
to give me your strength…
for all eternity.
-What's with him?
-Those guys…
Their friend just died,
but they haven't even batted an eyelid.
I'm sorry. This is a bad habit of mine.
I let my emotions get the better of me.
Don't worry about it.
We don't need weaklings.
Just make sure you fight well enough
to make up the numbers.
Yoh…
Lyserg!
Are you all right?
I'm so cold…
I feel like I could
lose consciousness any minute…
Those bitten by my fangs
become vampires themselves, loyal to me.
What are you saying?
What's Dracula doing out here
in broad daylight, anyway?
Silence!
What would a foolish human know?
In what world could a creature that turns
to dust in the sunlight possibly exist?
In what world could a creature that has
its eyes burned by the cross exist?
Don't you dare liken me to a fantasy
conceived of by foolish humans!
First, I'll wash out that mouth of yours--
Always be aware
of your surroundings, asshole.
I'm the one you're fighting.
-Ryu!
-Stay back if you're scared, Horohoro.